en fait mouche l'ingénieur manufacturier
de formation j'ai été embauché dans les
15 dernières années dans différentes
industries pour augmenter l'efficacité
de chaînes de production puissamment
interpol et devoirs qui aurait pas
vraiment d'outils existants pour les
gens du zune la venue des ipad 2 ou
changer la donne dans l'industrie on a
pu développer une plateforme mobile donc
de rendre disponible aux gens du sinn se
promener avec ipad d'avoir accès à leurs
données en temps réel donc on installe
un capteur qui vaut soient comptés qui
vaut prendre un poids sur une balance
par exemple puis qui va envoyer sur
directement dans une base de données qui
est notre logiciel taillebourg ensuite
les logiciels vont venir affiché sur
fond d'indicateurs de performance pour
que les gens du sinn plus voir leur
performance est également réagir le plus
rapidement possible on est mis en alerte
après 120 secondes d'arrêt machine donc
ça donne un signal tout de suite à notre
superviseur sur le plancher qui elle
peut prendre des actions tous le tower
qui qu'est ce qui se passe pourquoi
qu'elle est arrêtée à ce qu'il faut j'en
vois un mécano ce que d'autres raisons
donc ça nous permet d'être très très
très proactifs est très rapidement si
vous aviez pas l'application ce sera
quoi la différence admettons que la
machine s'arrête à lbv ans après ne peut
être seulement bull ou trois minutes de
plus par un ray machine pour que
l'information se rendent directement à
notre super bizarre mais ce 2 à 3 me de
plus pour nous c'est vraiment des gros
gains de production
donc pour nous c'est vraiment on est
dans le conte président du fan thiaulins
donc de sauver 2 3 mené plusieurs fois
par jour plusieurs fois par semaine
c'est vraiment important donc c'est
vraiment de réagir encore plus
rapidement qu'on est obligé de la faire
auparavant